in search of answers to their inquiring
questions people have been observing the
star-spangled sky for thousands of years
natural laws slowly but inevitably
yielded to their efforts and revealed
the true magnitude of space
the bright sun the mysterious moon and
planets traversing the sky following
intricate trajectories
all these amazing and unusual objects
are part of the solar system
today i'm inviting you to join me on a
journey that will allow us to get to
know some of the most remarkable ones
closer we will start out immersing
ourselves in the past to witness the
disappearance of dinosaurs from the face
of the earth and the formation of our
planet has the continents slowly shifted
to shape its surface we know today
after that we will fly over the surface
of mars and check out the most exciting
features of its terrain
next our journey will take us to the
asteroid belt which is literally stacked
with secrets and treasures and then we
will make kwawa's acquaintance a
mysterious object located at the very
edge of the system
at the end we're always as far away from
our earth as to be able to observe the
solar system from without
the senses of the interstellar space
probes that left the earth decades ago
will become our eyes
in spite of all challenges they have to
face
they still continue their arduous
journey through millions of kilometers
of space vacuum
[Music]
cosmo
the first in outer space
roughly 66 million years ago our planet
went through one of the most large-scale
extinction events in the history of
multicellular life forms
entire classes of species were wiped off
the face of the earth
others changed beyond all recognition in
order to adapt to the new conditions and
survive
the reasons for this dramatic event are
still not known for certain
still there is no doubt that the
cretaceous paleogene extinction made
great changes to what our planet looked
like
the majestic and horrifying dinosaurs
were superseded by creatures not less
impressive
mammals
three-fourths of all living organisms on
earth died out in the cretaceous
paleogene extinction almost all
creatures heavier than 25 kilos ceased
to be including practically all
non-avian dinosaurs
this tragic event heralded the end of
the mesozoic and the beginning of the
cenozoic the geologic era that is still
not over it is divided into three
periods of various duration which are
different both in terms of climate and
diversity of the biosphere
the first and longest is known as the
paleogene
it began around 66 million years ago and
continued for 43 million years
in the first 10 million years of the
paleogene the earth's biosphere was
recovering from the hard blow dealt by
the mass extinction
this geological epoch is referred to as
the paleocene
since great numbers of dinosaurs and
other species of the cretaceous had
perished there were lots of vacant
ecological niches for the taking these
were promptly filled by the new masters
of our planet mammals
the geography of the earth of that
period was drastically different from
what we're used to seeing today
looking at a map of that prehistoric
earth we would already be able to make
out the familiar continents but they
were positioned slightly differently
thus north and south americas were
separated by tropical seas while the
indian subcontinent was just starting to
make for the asian shores
the prehistoric ocean known as the
tethys still lay between africa and
eurasia but was already largely giving
way due to the movements of tectonic
plates the climate of the epoch was
warmer and more stable than today's most
of the planet was covered with dense and
lush tropical forests
the overwhelming majority of the living
creatures of the day were quite small
thanks to the abundance of vegetable
food they quickly propagated and spread
across more and more new areas this is
when the prehistoric ancestors of most
of today's mammals thrived
for example the warm forests of the
paleogene were inhabited by my acids
small and deft predators that looked
like martins it is believed that they
were the progenitors of all today's rich
diversity of mammal predators
at around the same time their lived
archaeo seats the prehistoric ancestors
of today's whales at the time however
they looked more like hippos they hadn't
gone to live in the sea yet but had made
their first steps in that direction
their limbs respiratory organs in the
inner rear had already started to adapt
to prolonged stays underwater
the next deparka planet went through was
the year scene
it began approximately 56 million years
ago and continued for slightly over 22
million years the contours of the
continents had already grown to be quite
recognizable
india had finally made it to the
southern shores of asia and as a result
of the collision of tectonic plates
giant rock folds formed
that is how the himalayas rose
the largest mountain range on our planet
today
even though some species of that time
already looked like some we might come
across today others were completely
different
an example of one of these is andrew
sarkis
one of the largest mammal predators that
has ever lived on the earth
its skull measured up to 84 centimeters
which is roughly one and a half times
more than that of the brown bear and its
bite is estimated to have been harder
than that of any of today's land
predators
it has been inferred from the deep tooth
sockets in andrew sarkis's skull where
mandible muscles were attached to which
leaves no doubts as to the bite's
crushing force
reconstruction of its skeleton shows
that the animal could measure over 4
meters in length and weigh as much as a
ton
still interestingly it looks like this
giant carnivore fell into the class of
primitive ungulates
research showed that andrew sarkis's
closest relatives were the prehistoric
sewer forms hippopotamus and citations
studies of a few unearthed fossils of
its skull and teeth show that the animal
must have been omnivorous and even
didn't mind eating carrion
unfortunately not many bones and fossils
of this fascinating creature have been
found and scientists are still at odds
as to the structure of its organism
habits and relation to other mammal
families
the oligoscene was the last debuck of
the paleogene it is posited that it
began around 33.9 million years ago and
was over about 23 million years ago
which makes it roughly 11 million years
long
this was a time of global cooling
warm tropical forests were gradually
superseded by endless prairies covered
with grasslands
this is when the antarctic glaciation
began and an icy shield transformed the
green continent of the pole into a
lifeless cold desert
australia continued to drift away from
the other continents while africa on the
contrary was making for the north to
meet europe
after a collision of tectonic plates
mountain ranges formed and that is how
the alps made their appearance on the
map of the world
around 26 28 million years ago the super
volcano lagarita furiously erupted on
the territory of today's colorado
in fact it was one of the major volcanic
emissions of the entire phanerozoic eon
an area of over 30 000 square meters was
buried under a layer of hot ash as much
as a hundred meters thick
all life within a huge radius around the
volcano was destroyed completely
amazingly
life is able to come to terms with any
disasters the earth of the time was
inhabited by fascinating creatures some
of which were not smaller than dinosaurs
in size for example indrik ethereum a
prehistoric herbivore related to rhinos
paraceratherium the largest of these
reached 4.8 meters in shoulder length
which is higher than a large african
elephant
thanks to their remarkably long neck
these giants were able to raise their
head up to seven meters above the ground
today's rhino would be able to pass
under its enormous progenitor's belly
while a human would hardly reach up to
touch its knee
with our mass reaching 20 tons these
giants were the largest land mammals of
all times
even brontosaurus the most massive of
land dinosaurs weighed just around 15
tons it still hasn't been established
for certain what endrick ethereum looked
like unfortunately
not one entire skeleton of these amazing
animals has been excavated so far only
separate fragments from different
animals of the species
most scientists agree that in spite of
their relation to rhinos endrick
ethereum didn't have a massive horn
although it may well have had a small
nose trunk like today's tapias
the trunk would have allowed it to pick
juicy leaves off treetops
these giant herbivores must have lived
in small herds and were constantly on
the move around vast stretches of land
roaming across their dominions in search
of food
unfortunately by the end of the
oligoscene indrik ethereum had died out
completely at around the same time the
areas they used to inhabit were explored
by prehistoric elephants alongside large
predators hyena dawns and amphicyonids
the latters are also known as bear dogs
it is thought that the emergence of new
large herbivores would have greatly
upset nature's balance and intricate
ethereum would have been forced to
fiercely compete for its food
famine and the threat from the new
dwellers of the asian prairie gradually
led to the herbivores giant's total
extinction apart from those mentioned
there were some other large predators
who were quite common on the earth and
the period from 37.2 to 28.4 million
years ago
and telodons fossilized remains of these
creatures have been found all over
eurasia being even toed ungulates and
telodons resembled wild boars although
in terms of evolution these creatures
are closer to hippos or even cetaceans
measuring up to two meters in length
they weighed over a tonne a meter long
head had huge jaws complete with all
sorts of teeth
sharp in sizes long fangs and wide flat
moles it is likely that intelligence
were omnivores with a preference for
predation not hampered by their
impressive size and bulk they were able
to develop remarkably high speeds so
chances of outrunning such a monster
were quite thin
a wild boar the size of a large bull
that prefers meat posed a serious threat
to any inhabitant of the earth of that
time
that is why it is hardly surprising that
intelligence successfully struggled for
their survival for such a considerable
time
the period in the history of our earth
that came next was the near gene
it began approximately 23 million years
ago and ended just 2
580 000 years ago
this is when our planet started to look
almost but not quite what it looks like
today
the continents shifted to their today's
positions on the planet's surface and
the looks of the most of the plants and
animals of the day grew to be familiar
to our eye with the earth's climate
gradually becoming colder and with
droughts occurring more often polar caps
were gradually growing which culminated
in a global glaciation at the end of the
neogene
the planet meanwhile was crawling with
all sorts of fascinating creatures
the deep sea dwellers were terrorized by
megalodon a giant shark measuring 15
meters in length and weighing up to 35
tons
on land
various gomphotheriums could be seen
creatures related to today's elephants
many of them were the proud owners of
four solid tusks as for the animal's
size some were larger than today's
african elephant whereas others were
quite modest in comparison
around 2.5 million years ago there
started the quaternary which is
currently the last geologic period in
the history of the earth it is
remarkable for the emergence and
evolution of homo sapiens as well as its
prehistoric ancestors
for example in the period from one
million years ago to a hundred thousand
years ago there lived gigantopithecus
one of the species of great human-like
apes known to science they measured
three to four meters in height and
weighed over 500 kilograms these
creatures lived on the territory of asia
and were related to today's orangutans
it appears that gigantopithecus would
not be able to climb trees like other
human-like apes on account of its mass
however some of them are known to have
dwelt in mountainous areas and made
homes and natural grottos caves and
ravines even though their diet is
believed to have consisted of mainly
bamboo
bones of herbivorous animals with tooth
marks were unearthed in their shelters
judging by these finds it is safe to
assume that these creatures didn't mind
meat and were omnivorous at the very
least the gigantopithecus skeleton is
similar to that of a gorilla so they
were likely to use all four limbs to
move around
besides these human-like apes had a
comparatively large brain which means
that they could be relatively
intelligent and were probably able to
even make primitive working tools
unfortunately the population of these
amazing giants sharply dropped when the
prehistoric ancestors of today's human
emerged and spread across the planet
by around one to three hundred thousand
years ago they had died out completely
sadly not many remains of
gigantopithecus had been found which
greatly impedes studying them
as they were spreading across the earth
primitive human tribes eliminated many
other creatures
one of their victims was megatherium a
giant ground sloth that used to inhabit
south america and part of north america
in the period from 2 million to 12 000
years ago
it was really a creature to marvel at
weighing up to four tons and measuring
around six meters in length
megatherium was quite as large as the
african elephant
which is all the more impressive as it
generally moved around on its hind legs
megatherium's happy days ended around 15
000 years ago when nomadic human tribes
came to south america the powerful but
sluggish giant was helpless under a
barrage of sharp spears and arrows and
very soon its population dropped to zero
other giants who supposedly became
extinct because of humans were
diprotodons which inhabited australia in
the period from 1.6 million years ago to
around 40 000 years ago these creatures
were the largest known marsupials and
they were related to wombats and koalas
some of these amazing animals reached as
much as 3 meters in length and 2 meters
in shoulder height as for the hamas they
weighed approximately three tons this
makes diprotodons quite as big as some
hippos
massive and herbivorous they dwelt on
massive woodland and coastal
grass-covered plains that abounded in
australia before humans had made their
appearance there
chronologically the extinction of the
marsupial giants coincides with first
human tribes arriving to this continent
still some scientists maintained that
the extinction was caused not by hunting
but an anomaly of the earth's magnetic
field together with a local temperature
decrease the heightened radiation
background coupled with cooling slowed
down plant growth which led to famine
among the herbivores
thus it appears that by and large the
tragedy was inevitable and the humans
simply brought it to a close faster
the last epoch of the quaternary the
holocene heralded a robust development
of the human civilization when homo
sapiens spread across the entire planet
and dominated all the other inhabitants
of our earth the downside of this
evolution is manifested in a number of
industrial disasters and irreversible
changes in nature's balance
for example it is due to human activity
that the greenhouse gases concentration
in the earth's atmosphere is getting
worse every year
this may globally negatively affect all
living things on our earth
from simplest bacteria
to elaborate multicellular organisms
unfortunately the number of fascinating
creatures living on our earth is going
down every year it is particularly
poignant to realize that they perish
because of human stupidity or ovaries on
controlled hunting irresponsible land
development and indifference to the
environment have already made scientists
speak of a new sixth grade extinction
event
whose consequences are potentially just
as grave as those of the previous five
will mankind stop before it eliminates
itself
how long should it take our planet to
recover from the consequences of the
technological progress
and will nature produce radically new
life forms that would weather this
crisis
just like it happened before
we can hardly realistically answer these
questions
mars lies approximately one and a half
times as far from the sun as the earth
in contrast to our planet its radius is
twice as small its mass is around 10.7
percent that of the earth and the
freefall acceleration on the surface is
almost three times as little the
temperature fluctuates between
153 degrees celsius below zero at the
poles and 35 degrees celsius above zero
at the equator
the area of mars's surface is roughly
the same as that of all our continents
combined
its terrain is extremely diverse
with some geological features
reminiscent of those of our planet and
others quite unique and peculiar
the surface of mars is currently closely
observed from the planet's orbit by
eight automatic space probes the data
collected by them reveals that there is
a vast light spot in the planet's
western hemisphere this region is the
largest volcano in the solar system and
it is known as olympus mans
today this is the starting point of our
tour around the red planet
olympus mons towers as high as 26
kilometers over the plains surrounding
it
this is roughly two and a half times the
height of mount everest
it is assumed to be a shield volcano
formed with multiple sheets of
solidified lava according to today's
assumptions about the planet's inner
makeup there are no tectonic plates
under the surface
which is why magma's eruption point can
remain in the same spot for a long time
for hundreds of millions and even
billions of years
that accounts for the fact why ejected
lava spills out to cover incredibly vast
areas with a layer that subsequently
turns into a rocky shield the average
diameter of olympus mons measures around
600 kilometers and its area is over 300
000 square kilometers
these figures are comparable with the
area of an average sized european
country like poland or italy
a giant depression formed with six cow
dairies or collapsed volcanic craters is
located in the center of the volcano the
diameter of the depression measures
around 85 kilometers and its depth
reaches as far down as three kilometers
olympus mons is so high that the
atmospheric pressure at the top is 50
times lower than at the foot
since the atmosphere on mars is about
160 times more rarefied than that of the
earth the conditions on top of the
volcano are slightly short of those in
the vacuum
that is why the red planet's highest
mountain cannot expect any visitor
probes the atmospheric density would be
too low for parachutes to slow down a
descending capsule with a mars rover
inside
with the average slope of olympus mons
quite small at only five percent the
volcano's edges and an almost sheer
abysses of up to seven kilometers high
it still hasn't been established for
certain how such enormous slopes came to
form according to some assumptions it
was done by an ancient ocean on mars
other hypotheses hold sandstorms
accountable which continuously rage in
this area
when we climb down from olympus mons and
fly over its surroundings we can see
that there are lots of overlapping
ridges and isolated mountains some of
these formations stretch as far as a
thousand kilometers from the volcano's
edge it is assumed that they may have
formed as the giant mountain slopes were
eroding or else due to movements of
ancient ice caps
whizzing on south east from olympus mons
we will find ourselves in a vast region
known as tharsis
this volcanic upland formed by
solidified streams of lava covers
roughly one-fourth of the entire
planet's surface its area of around 30
million square kilometers is comparable
with that of africa
interestingly the upland is 10
kilometers higher than the plains
surrounding it
and its age could be about 3.7 billion
years
there are a great number of volcanoes
here some of which only slightly smaller
than olympus mons aseamons for example
rises as high up as 19 kilometers which
makes it the second highest peak on mars
with a summit caldera measuring 110
kilometers the overall diameter of the
mountain is over 400 kilometers
a unique natural phenomenon can be
observed over the volcano every year for
a short time
as sun rays warm the mountain slopes
small dust spirals into a dense cloud
helped along by airstreams going upward
this cloud may float up to 30 kilometers
above our sea mons may be scattered by
winds across vast areas
vertical pits can be seen in different
places all over the upland they're quite
deep with the bottoms quite unobservable
the diameter of the largest one measures
around 150 meters and its depth cannot
be less than 178 meters
these pits are thought to be collapsed
lava tubes
tharsis is made up of dozens of
overlapping shield volcanoes
in the billions of years of their
eruptions great amounts of co2 and water
vapor were released into the martian
atmosphere
mathematical modelling shows that the
amount would be enough to shroud the
planet with an atmosphere one and a half
times as dense as that of the earth
these estimates are in direct evidence
of the fact that in the past conditions
on mars may have been more favorable for
life to originate there than now
with its gravity comparatively weak
however the planet failed to retain its
atmosphere and was eventually stripped
of it
moving on to the east from the plateau
we will get to the region known as
valles marineris
it is a network of gargantuan canyons
stretching for up to 4
500 kilometers
the width of the canyon reaches 600
kilometers and it's more than 11
kilometers deep
images revealed that the slopes of most
of the canyons in the central and
western parts of valles marineris have a
stratified structure typical of deposits
at the bottom of a large body of water
it is quite likely that the canyons used
to be completely submerged underwater in
the distant past there are some truly
invaluable paleontological finds to be
extracted from the rock deposits in this
region
the eastern part of the valleys are
areas with a rather chaotic relief
there are vast labyrinths made up of
comparatively small canyons abysses
mountains and plateaus
further north the terrain evens out into
a relatively smooth plain known as
grey's planitia
its vast areas became the final resting
place for the debris of the sojourner
mars rover and also for the viking one
probe which sent the first color images
of martian landscapes to the earth as
far back as in 1976
according to the widely accepted
hypothesis today valles marineris came
to be in the early stages of the
planet's formation erosion and
geological processes were to deepen and
widen the canyons later on one version
has it that the systems of casmatis is
thought to have formed after volcanic
eruptions on the tharsis upland
another version claims utopia planitia
to be the cause for their formation
which lies on the other side of the
planet
this vast round lowland is likely to be
an impact crater from an extremely large
asteroid that would have hit the
planet's surface
the plunicious diameter measures some
3300 kilometers the terrain of the
surface itself is rather flat and smooth
there were several attempts to explore
utopia planitia by different space
probes
in 1979 the viking 2 lander beamed back
panoramic images of its surface to the
earth in 2016 the charade radar on the
mro probe located rich deposits of water
ice mixed with dust underground
in may 2021 the chinese rover jurong
touched down on utopia planitia it has
covered over 1 000 metres of the red
planet's surface by now and has beamed
back hundreds of images unfortunately it
cannot dig as far down as the water
carrying layer with the latter as deep
as 1 to 10 meters down
in the north utopia planitia borders on
vestitus borealis a giant lowland
surrounding the northern part of the
planet and covering about 40 percent of
its total area
moving south west from the center of
utopia planitia we will reach
icidisplenicia
the region on its western edge has been
the focus of people's special attention
for almost eight months now
of course it is all about the jezreel
crater it is likely that millions of
years ago there used to be a body of
water here that has dried up by now
the perseverance mars rover and
ingenuity the first ever helicopter
flown beyond the earth have been
exploring the bottom of the crater since
the 18th of february 2021
the jezreel crater was chosen for the
mission because it appeared one of the
most promising places to discover traces
of martian life
the crater is posited to have formed
around 4 billion years ago after a
massive celestial body fell on mars
the impact crater measured some 49
kilometers
as i've already mentioned it is thought
that it used to be filled with water and
the hesperion of the geological history
of mars is singled out as the most
likely period for that
the hesperians started some three and a
half billion years ago and continued for
around a billion years atmospheric
pressure on the planet at the time is
estimated to have been comparable with
that on the earth with the surface
temperature reaching 50 degrees celsius
rock samples recently extracted from the
crater's bottom by the perseverance
rover are hard evidence of that
they still have to be transported to the
earth for deeper analysis but it is
clear even now that at some point the
rocks have continuously been in close
contact with liquid water
perseverance has already delighted
scientists with great amounts of useful
data and the mission is still far from
being completed
the probe is designed for 14 years of
operation which means that there are
still hundreds of fines to extract and
kilometers of martian terrain to cover
that is why our tour around martian
expanses is not yet over
the solar system appears to be a
perfectly tuned mechanism when viewed at
large
by contrast there's a real realm of
chaos between the orbits of mars and
jupiter
this is where hundreds of thousands of
small celestial objects whizz around
space in all sorts of directions
occasionally crossing other objects
orbits they sometimes get in each
other's way and produce thousands of
shards and bits on collision
with this area of space highly
changeable
it is hardly possible to predict what it
will look like in the distant future
of course we'll be talking about the
main asteroid belt one of the most
changeable and mysterious areas in the
solar system today over 300 000 small
celestial bodies found here have been
given names and numerical designations
interestingly their overall number may
well reach over a million
the starting point of studying the
asteroid belt may be defined at 1801
when astronomers spotted a mysterious
object in the sky after a long and hard
search for the fifth planet
in terms of its parameters it appeared
to be a planet but happened to be so
small that even the most advanced
telescopes of the day couldn't
distinguish its disk
the researchers saw the newly discovered
object as a bright dot like a star
it was dubbed series and very soon
similar celestial objects of this class
were discovered a new term had to be
introduced to refer to them these
unusual astronomical bodies came to be
called asteroids which literally means
star-like
apart from asteroids this area in the
solar system contains great amounts of
cosmic dust while slowly spiraling up
its tiny particles scatter sun rays and
create a very faint white glow
this glow is referred to as zodiacal
light
interestingly in equatorial areas of the
earth it can be seen with the naked eye
for a long time the following hypothesis
used to be widely accepted asteroid belt
objects were thought to be debris of a
destroyed planet
however today this assumption doesn't
really hold water
first of all the mass total of all the
objects of the main asteroid belt is too
small and equals just 3 times 10 to the
power of 21 kilograms
or 4 percent the mass of the moon
even allowing for the fact that the
greater part of asteroids would have
left about a while ago the total mass of
the rocky debris still falls short of
making up an object with dimensions
comparable to those of a proper planet
secondly estimates show that large
celestial objects cannot form in this
area of the solar system on account of
jupiter's gravitational influence
mathematical modelling revealed that the
largest formations in the asteroid belt
have never measured over a thousand
kilometers in diameter the gravitational
influence of their mighty giant neighbor
rendered their raw bits highly unstable
which made potential protoplanets
collide and disintegrate into smaller
bits
traces of these collisions can still be
observed
most objects of the main belt group
together to form the so-called asteroid
families populations of asteroids of
similar makeup and of the same origin it
is thought that they formed as a result
of such destructive collisions
the borders of the main asteroid belt
are rather blurred
most of the objects making it up lie
within 2.06 to 3.27 astronomical units
from the sun
these boundaries are predefined by
jupiter's tidal forces and are referred
to as kirkwood gaps any celestial
objects getting into these zones
experience the massive gas giant's
strong gravitational influence which
destabilizes their orbits this is the
reason why the space object count here
is considerably lower than beyond
kirkwood gaps can be found not only on
the conventional borders of the belt but
inside it too
two of the most clearly defined gaps lie
2.5 and 2.8 astronomical units away from
the sun the asteroid belt is also
conventionally divided into two large
areas inner and out about
the border between them is a kirkwood
gap with a radius measuring 2.5
astronomical units which coincides with
the highest orbital resonance with
jupiter it's in the outer part of the
main belt that the largest object in
this area of the solar system is
situated
series this celestial object used to be
thought a planet then an asteroid but
eventually in 2006 it was given the
status of a dwarf planet it was possible
to do so thanks to the fact that ceres
has a spherical shape unlike the
absolute majority of the other objects
and the belt
its diameter measures around
940 kilometers and its mass 9.4 times 10
to the power of 20 kilograms which
incidentally accounts for around a third
of the overall mass of the asteroid belt
this makes series approximately 6 000
times lighter than our planet
the furthest point of the dwarf planet's
orbit from the sun is 2.9 astronomical
units
when ceres is at its perihelion the
distance to our system's center measures
around two and a half astronomical units
at this point the planetoid surface
temperature may reach
239 kelvin or 33 degrees celsius below
zero although its average temperature is
noticeably smaller
at just
167 kelvin
or 106 degrees celsius below zero
the celestial body is thought to be made
up of a rocky core enveloped in a cryo
mantle around a hundred kilometers thick
water ice accounts for up to half of the
dwarf planet's volume or 20 to 30
percent of its mass
the inner part of the belt harbors the
largest and most massive known asteroid
in the solar system
vesta
the object's average diameter measures
roughly
525 kilometers
and its mass is around 2.6 times 10 to
the power of 20 kilograms which is
almost four times as little as that of
ceres the asteroid's orbit is rather
elongated with its ophelian 2.57
astronomical units and its perihelion
around 2.15 astronomical units away it
takes the celestial body 3.6 earth years
to complete a full orbit around the sun
vesta is also remarkable for being the
only asteroid visible to the naked eye
it can be seen not only on account of
its impressive dimensions but also
thanks to its comparatively light
surface that reflects about 42 percent
of light shed on it
besides the minimal distance between
vesta and the earth isn't that great at
just
177 million kilometers or 1.18
astronomical units
it is assumed that vesta is a
fully-fledged planet in terms of its
inner makeup
it appears to have a metallic core made
up of nickel and iron as well as a rocky
mantle the surface temperature of the
asteroid is currently fluctuating
between -190
and minus 20 degrees celsius but it used
to be much warmer in the past
dark areas to be seen on the surface in
the western hemisphere are highly likely
to be the sword planes such terrain
features may have formed as a result of
volcanic activity or collision events
with massive astronomical bodies the
most outstanding geological feature on
the asteroid is the giant impact crater
referred to as rear silvia whose
diameter measures up to 500 kilometers
and its depth is around 25 000 meters
the second largest mountain in the solar
system is situated at its center
towering higher than 22 kilometers
impressively the crater's diameter
almost equals vesta's size it looks like
the asteroid collided with a really
large object at some point in the past
the collision would have produced not
only the rear silvia crater but also a
great number of small bits which are now
classified as the family of wester's
numerous asteroids
the family counts over 15 thousand
objects making up around five percent of
all celestial bodies of the main belt
known to science today
it is posited that most asteroid
families came to be as a result of
destructive collisions of two large
celestial objects
sometimes the debris are mutually
attracted by gravity forces which
usually blend them into a new
astronomical object
however it would have lost its
monolithic nature
and sometimes astronomers informally
call such formations rubble piles
for example sylvia one of the largest
objects in the asteroid belt seems to
fall into this category of celestial
bodies its parameters are
384 by 262
by
232 kilometers with a mass 1.5 times 10
to the power of 19 kilograms
this makes the asteroid's average
density just 20 percent higher than that
of water
estimates show that cavities may account
for 25 to 60 percent of its volume
it takes sylvia 6.5 years to complete a
full orbit around the sun
the object's orbit's furthest point from
the center of the system is up to 3.7
astronomical units in its perihelion
silvia gets as close to the sun as 3.2
astronomical units
it is assumed that some bits of debris
left after a collision are not attracted
to other bits but rather become
satellites of the new celestial body
silvia is known to have two such
companions romulus with a diameter
measuring 18 kilometers and remus
measuring around seven kilometers
their makeup hasn't been studied yet and
it is highly likely that these objects
are not monolithic either
besides silvia may theoretically have
smaller satellites as well which haven't
been detected yet
palace is another remarkable object in
the asteroid belt it was discovered back
in 1802 right after ceres and is the
second largest asteroid in the bout
the average diameter of the celestial
body is around 512 kilometers and its
mass is roughly 2 times 10 to the power
of 20 kilograms which is approximately
25 percent less than that of vesta
the asteroid's orbit is exceptionally
elongated and tilts to the ecliptic
plane at 35 degrees
that is the reason why the astronomical
body is so hard to investigate with
probes
as for its orbital period it takes
palace around 4.6 years to orbit the sun
in the course of which the distance to
the system center changes more than one
and a half times with its perihelion 2.1
astronomical units its aphelion is 3.4
astronomical units away palace's surface
is widely pockmarked with craters much
more so than the largest series of vesta
studies of the chemical composition of
the asteroid's surface reveal that it
mostly consists of silicate rocks with
small amounts of iron and water just
like vesta this celestial body is
thought to be one of the few potential
protoplanets that are still around which
means that studying it may yield
important information about the
formation process of the solar system
unlike vesta most asteroids cannot be
seen either with the naked eye or
through amateur telescopes
one of these elusive objects is called
interrumnia
admittedly one of the most mysterious
objects of the main asteroid belt
this is an irregular shaped asteroid
with parameters
362 by 348 by 310 kilometers
and its mass accounts for roughly 1.2
percent of the overall mass of all
objects and the bout in spite of its
relatively large size however interamlia
remains largely understudied
one of the difficulties thwarting
scientific progress here is the
asteroid's dark surface which absorbs
around 93 percent of light shed on it
interamnia falls into the exceptionally
rare spectral class f which is a
subclass of carbonaceous asteroids
research of its reflection shows that
the color of the celestial body's
surface is even which means that
interimlia hasn't experienced big
collisions for quite a long time
inter amnious density is not that great
at just twice that of water
the asteroid is thought to be made up of
a hard rocky core enveloped in a thick
layer of ice the surface is covered with
great amounts of fine dark dust
it takes in terramia around 5 years and
four months to complete a full orbit
around the sun
itsophilian is on the opposite side from
four largest objects of the main bout
and the distance from the asteroid to
the sun varies from 2.5 to 3.5
astronomical units
in theory interramania's orbit crosses
the trajectories of such large objects
as series and palace but estimates show
that chances of their colliding with
each other are small
there are millions of objects in the
main belt from dwarf planets to tiny
meteoroids the size of a cobblestone
however distances between them measure
thousands upon thousands or even
millions of kilometers
that is why spacecraft crossing the bout
would be running an almost negligible
risk of getting hit by any astronomical
body
still mathematical modelling shows that
around once every 10 million years some
remarkable collisions take place in this
part of the solar system that produce
new debris
even though a manned mission to
asteroids in the main belt will not be
in the pipeline for a long while
some of the asteroids there have been
studied with the help of interplanetary
space probes for example the dawn probe
carried out observations of ceres
investor in the period from 2011 to
2016.
quite recently the space probe lucy
blasted off the surface of the earth
even though its main goal is the
so-called jupiter trojans the spacecraft
will approach the object known as donald
johansen in the main belt and take its
pictures in 2025
also the launch of the psyche project is
scheduled for july 2022
with the largest known metallic asteroid
of the main belt as its target
within the mission the probe is planned
to reach its destination by early 2026
and remain in the asteroid belt for at
least 21 months while studying the
asteroids terrain makeup and magnetic
field
between the orbits of mars and jupiter
there lies the asteroid belt
a vast area which is home to hundreds of
thousands of relatively small celestial
bodies
series a dwarf planet with a diameter
measuring slightly over 950 kilometers
is the largest of the lot
the rest of the space objects in this
part of the solar system are
considerably smaller
with some of them seen as potential
dwarf planets there is no doubt that
their overwhelming majority are
asteroids
according to data from february 2021
over a million celestial bodies of this
kind have been detected so far most of
which are located in the asteroid belt
[Music]
the oort cloud is thought to contain by
far larger numbers of these but it is
too challenging to detect them due to
their small size and the distances
between us and them which are too great
these celestial objects may well be
numerous in the asteroid belt but their
mass total is not that great at
approximately three times 10 to the
power of 21 kilograms
just to compare it is only four percent
the mass of the moon
according to the most widespread
classification all objects of this type
fall into three big groups carbonaceous
silicate
and metallic
the first group contains most asteroids
in fact roughly 75 of all known
asteroids in the solar system are c-type
these are made up mostly of graphite and
suit the simplest modifications of
carbon
by contrast silicate asteroids account
for approximately 17 of the overall
count these are rocky celestial bodies
made up of predictably enough silicate
varieties of rock
the other eight percent of asteroids
fall into the category of metallic ones
and these are the most valuable from the
point of view of commercial exploitation
and mining
as the name suggests metallic asteroids
are made up of metals and metal
compounds including those rare defined
on our earth the reason for this is that
as our planet was forming most heavy
elements like gold tungsten and platinum
were pulled to the center of the planet
by gravity forces there they formed a
massive core and mantle
only small amounts of these elements
remained at a comparatively small depth
where largely thanks to geological
processes they formed metalliferous
deposits
the largest known m-type asteroid psyche
with a diameter measuring roughly 186
kilometers contains around 17
quadrillion tons of metal ore which is
at least 20 000 times more than all
deposits of these resources that our
planet's crust is supposed to contain
even a comparatively small metallic
asteroid with a diameter of one
kilometer contains as much metal ore as
is extracted by all countries in the
world in the course of a year
apart from iron asteroids may be made up
of precious and rare earth metals like
gold and platinum the element indium
which is used in production of touch
screens is of special interest as well
as extremely rare osmium rhenium and
rhodium
another important factor is great
amounts of water ice to be found in
asteroids water is not only
indispensable for life forms but is also
a resource that oxygen may be produced
with
as for hydrogen extracted by splitting
water using the method of electrolysis
it may be used as fuel for spacecraft
as we can see small celestial bodies in
the solar system may potentially turn
out to be almost inexhaustible mines of
valuable natural resources but are we
technologically ready to carry out
prospecting and mining operations on
asteroids plans to extract natural
resources from space objects may appear
rather unreal obviously mankind is not
yet capable of constructing a giant
platform that would capture and process
one asteroid after another
this does sound like a sci-fi movie
today
however projects of a smaller scale are
quite feasible even now
when plans are made to extract this or
that resource a factor to be reckoned
with is the ratio of the extraction
costs and the value of the resource
natural resources of our planet are
gradually getting depleted which means
that their value is inevitably and
inexorably going up
space technologies on the other hand are
getting cheaper which makes some
commercial space projects almost cost
efficient
most small celestial objects may well
line the asteroid belt but many are
still scattered across the inner part of
the solar system
hundreds of such-like objects get close
to the earth or collide with it every
year
as a rule they are relatively small
objects and cannot cause any serious
destruction
some of them are made up of tough rocks
or metals others contain substantial
amounts of water ice
if a heavy chunk of water ice like that
were to be captured and transported to a
desired spot it would potentially
satisfy the needs of the international
space station for many years to come
this is just one example of how
attractive and useful they can be
with all the obvious technological
shortcomings taken do due notice of a
number of projects already underway in
this field
one of these is the deep space
industries company also known as dsi
founded in 2013 it deals with designing
spaceships and propulsion systems some
claims made by the company
representatives may well sound fanciful
and presumptuous to mention but one dsi
promises to start mining natural
resources on an industrial scale and
asteroids close to the earth as soon as
this decade
the extracted materials are supposed to
be transported to the earth while it is
envisaged that in the future they will
be used actually in space for such
undertakings as construction works and
production processes away from our
planet
time will show whether these bold
projects will be put into practice
speaking about future plans for
exploration of small celestial bodies in
the solar system in general
there are three main approaches that can
be singled out
the first one involves extracting crude
ore and transporting it to a processing
point which may be either in space or on
the earth
the advantage of this approach is the
option of employing automated mechanisms
that won't need to be mount directly
although on the downside transporting
large amounts of heavy rocks is
admittedly a rather complicated and
costly procedure
the second approach involves processing
extracted ore on site
both the volume and mass of the final
product will be considerably lower
whereas the transportation will be more
cost efficient with all useless waste
rock successfully lost
however in this case another tough
challenge will have to be faced namely
the construction of a metal processing
plant in space the technological process
of extracting pure base metal out of ore
requires both great amounts of energy
and additional reagents like carbon or
big volumes of water
organizing the entire cycle of
production in such conditions may prove
to be quite a gruelling ordeal
the third approach involves transporting
a celestial body to a processing plant
in space that would have been
constructed and prepared in advance
this centralized approach would solve
many of the issues implied by the
previous two although a certain
technological advancement is called for
for example space objects may be
transported by pinpoint blasting towing
or else using a pulse detonation engine
of some sort that would be mounted
directly on the transported body's
surface
unfortunately at this point of our
development mankind isn't capable of
transporting more or less significant
space objects
incidentally first experiments of this
kind are already in the pipeline for
example in the upcoming years the
european space agency is planning to
organize a collision between the small
near-earth asteroid dimorphous and a
man-made spacecraft the collision will
not only help to establish the asteroids
makeup but also see how the collision
will affect its orbit
as for the technologies of tearing
things around in space eventually
they'll by all means develop and get
both cheaper and more reliable
processing extracted resources right
there in space implies that a large
orbital station has to be constructed
that would house dozens of people
in space a city like this will
inevitably encounter a number of issues
in terms of life support power supply
and last but not least trivial cooling
or smelting is carried out in extremely
high temperatures and heat dissipation
in a vacuum may prove to be a serious
issue
rare metals that are especially valuable
tend to be distributed rather unevenly
in a iraq
their extraction from the rock and
purification involve exceptionally
elaborate technological processes
organizing complex production cycles at
a space plant like this as well as
maintaining its reliable and smooth
operation is hardly possible without a
considerable number of staff both
technical people and scientists residing
in orbit
having to create an environment suitable
for prolonged stays of large numbers of
people outside the earth must be
reckoned with and remains high on the
list of priorities
still i will repeat myself by saying
that technologies are constantly moving
forward at a breakneck speed and what
would appear to be unreal even yesterday
is already firmly establishing itself in
our today's life what we must remember
however is that the world needs care and
we must introduce ourselves to a
profit-seeking lot who are only after
the resources knowledge and living space
whether it is only our earth or the
entire solar system we must not harm or
destroy them in our search for resources
the beginning of the 21st century
heralded a whole bunch of sensational
discoveries in astronomy
a number of objects close to pluto in
terms of their size were detected one
after another in remote areas of the
solar system
one of the first objects to be spotted
was kwawa
the discovery was made by chadwick
trujillo and michael brown in 2002 while
there were studying images of the star
sky taken in palomar observatory
at first the detected object was thought
to be slightly smaller than pluto but
after double checking the planetoid
turned out to be much smaller
still this celestial body remains one of
the top 10 largest bodies in the kuiper
belt
this area in space looks like a
remarkably wide ring encompassing the
solar system beyond neptune's orbit to
give you an idea of its size here are
its basic parameters its inner radius
measures approximately 30 astronomical
units with its outer radius roughly 55
astronomical units apart from a number
of small objects there are several
relatively large dwarf planets to be
found here pluto aerys makimaki and
others
kwawa is one of these too
now let's talk about it in more detail
this celestial body looks like a
flattened ellipsoid its equatorial
diameter measures about a thousand one
hundred and thirty eight kilometers and
the distance between its poles is 1030
kilometers or so
this makes kwawa's diameter about twice
as small as pluto's with sharon just
barely beating it in terms of size
mass is estimated at around 1.4 times 10
to the power of 21 kilograms which makes
it around 10 times lighter than pluto
kwawa's average density is approximately
200 kilograms per cubic meter which is
typical of dwarf planets
the planetoid is thought to be made up
of mostly rocks and water vapor
just like other objects in the kuiper
belt
estimates show the intensity of
radioactive decay in koala's interior to
be too low to melt the lower layers of
ice that is why in all likelihood there
is no subsurface ocean under the ice
shell on this planetoid
now let's see how freezing cold it is on
kwawa its average surface temperature is
predictably low at approximately 44
kelvin or
229 degrees celsius below zero
even at temperatures this low frozen
gases in the vacuum of space gradually
vaporize
and form a remarkably rarefied
atmosphere that is made up mostly of
methane
however the density of the planetoid's
atmosphere is at least a hundred million
times lower than that of the earth
kwawa is known to be a rather dark
celestial body reflecting from ten to
twenty percent of all light shed on it
it has a reddish hue just like many
other celestial objects in those areas
of space
this color comes from impurities
containing phthalins complex polymers
originating in frozen methane when it is
exposed to ultraviolet rays still it is
assumed that quava contains considerably
less ice and frozen gases than larger
trans-neptunian objects mostly on
account of its more modest dimensions
and a weaker gravity
the free-fall acceleration on kuawa's
surface is estimated at a measly 0.29
meters per square second which is about
33 times slower than on our planet
this means that when hypothetically
placed on the planetoid surface a human
would weigh just two or three kilos
investigations and observations show the
surface of the object to contain
crystalline water ice
however the detected modification of ice
may form only at temperatures not lower
than 110 kelvin or
163 degrees celsius below zero which is
at least 66 kelvin higher than the
current average temperature on the
planetide
according to one of the hypotheses as to
this discrepancy the detected ice may
have formed in the dwarf planet's
interior where the temperatures are
higher on account of radioactive decay
of heavy elements
the ice probably got ejected as a result
of cryo-volcanic activity and so spilled
out on the surface
another hypothesis claims the anomalous
ice to have appeared on a planetoid as a
result of meteorite bombardment
spectral analyses reveal kwawa to
contain small amounts of solidified
methane and ethane although here their
concentration is considerably lower than
on the surfaces of other larger
trans-neptunian objects
by slowly evaporating frozen
hydrocarbons replenish guava's
atmosphere although the planetoid's
gravity isn't strong enough to keep the
gas molecules close to the surface
thus kwawa is slowly but surely getting
stripped of its atmosphere and in
billions of years time will lose it
completely
like most celestial objects the
planetoid rotates on its axis
the rotation period hasn't been gauged
exactly yet but judging by its
luminosity which repeatedly changes
following a certain pattern it is
estimated at roughly 18 hours
kwawa follows an almost circular orbit
around the sun which takes it slightly
less than 289 years to complete the
orbit eccentricity is just .04 which is
two and a half times more than that of
our earth and twice as small as that of
mars
it takes sunlight about five hours to
reach qawa's surface
it has been calculated that the
planetoid last reached its ophelia in
with a distance to the center of our
system approximately 45 astronomical
units
now kwawa is on its way to its orbit's
perihelion
which is estimated to be reached in
about 2075.
the distance between the planetoid and
the sun will be 42 astronomical units at
that point
[Music]
its orbit doesn't allow kwawa to
approach neptune closely enough to
experience this planet's gravity pull
such like space objects are referred to
as kubiwanos and kwawa is a typical
representative of this class alongside
varuna and makimaki
kwawa's orbit is tilted to the ecliptic
plane at an angle of 8 degrees
and this fact leads scientists to
believe it to confirm that neptune did
have some gravitational influence on the
dwarf planet a long while ago
currently kwawa is known to have only
one satellite
dubbed wayward it was detected in 2006.
this small astronomical body follows a
moderately elongated orbit around the
planetoid
itsophilian is estimated at
approximately sixteen and a half
thousand kilometers
in its perihelion whey what is anything
from twelve thousand to thirteen
thousand kilometers away from the
surface of the dwarf planet
the satellite completes a full orbit
around kwawa roughly every 12 and a half
days
to date its orbits other parameters
haven't been gauged with any degree of
certainty yet wayward's diameter
measures around 170 kilometers assuming
the dwarf planet and its satellite are
similar in terms of their makeup
weiwat should be two thousand times
lighter
the gravity of an object this light is
not enough to make it spherical
this must be the reason why wayward
shape is irregular just like that of
most other asteroids and small
astronomical bodies in the solar system
taking into account the current stage of
space technology's development it is
estimated that it would take a space
probe slightly over 13 and a half years
to reach kwawa
to date only the new horizons probe has
approached it closest
in 2016 it took a number of images of
kwawa from a distance of 14 astronomical
units
it is known that astronomers in the us
and china considered an option of
sending an automatic space probe to
remote objects of the solar system
and kwawa was on the list of potential
objects of interest
still so far there were no official
announcements and confirmations as to
planned scientific missions there
and so just like countless other worlds
out there kwawa is still waiting for its
pioneers
roughly half a year before this video
was posted on the 15th of april 2021 the
automatic space probe new horizons
became the fifth spacecraft in the
history of the humanity to go beyond the
point of 50 astronomical units from the
sun
it was the voyages that had crossed this
mark before with the probes pioneer 10
and pioneer 11 the first ever to do so
none of these space wanderers are likely
to ever return to the earth
with some of them still active on their
missions others have gone quiet forever
spacecraft
new horizons
start of mission 19th of january 2006
distance to earth 52 astronomical units
speed
14 kilometers per second or three
astronomical units per year
main goal pluto and sharon
mission status successfully completed
condition operational
just like most other interplanetary
space probes new horizons performed a
gravity assist maneuver near jupiter
before setting out to its target
not only did it greatly boost the
spacecraft's speed but also allowed it
to capture high quality images of the
largest planet in the solar system
alongside its satellites
besides the probe's cameras captured the
first video ever of an erupting volcano
on the surface of jupiter's satellite io
after the gravity boost had been
completed the probe made for the main
target
pluto
the spacecraft reached the planetoids
environs in january 2015. the mission's
main goal was to explore pluto and
sharon from different perspectives that
involved taking photos of and mapping
these remote space object surfaces
in addition the probe estimated the
magnetic fields values and the solar
wind activity close to the objects and
collected information about their
atmospheres and surface reflection
properties
it goes without saying that the program
also involved search for pluto's as yet
undetected satellites and more accurate
measurements of pluto's orbits
parameters
having completed the main mission the
probe continued to be useful
it flew beyond pluto's orbit and went on
to explore objects in the kuiper belt
that is how images of kawa r1 and
darakoth were produced
thanks to the probe's cameras the
distances to the star's proxima centauri
and wolf 359 were measured
unfortunately the radioisotope generator
on board the spacecraft is expected to
start running low from 2026 and
eventually all the meters will switch
off one after another
new horizons will continue on its way
beyond the boundaries of the solar
system and by the year 2038 the distance
between the probe and the sun will have
grown to be a hundred astronomical units
by that time the energy generator on
board the spacecraft will have stopped
operating completely and it will be
impossible to get any connection with it
following a hyperbolic orbit
new horizons will exit our system never
to come back
the same thing happened with two other
probes pioneer 10 and pioneer 11.
they hit an escape trajectory from the
solar system a while ago
in fact they were the first automatic
space probes ever to be sent into
interstellar space by humans
spacecraft pioneer 10
start of mission
3rd of march 1972 distance to earth
127 astronomical units
speed approximately 12 kilometers per
second or two and a half astronomical
units per year
main goal jupiter
mission status successfully completed
condition not operational
the spacecraft reached jupiter's system
on the 4th of december 1973 after
completing a
641-day journey through space
during the mission images of the gas
giant's surface and its largest
satellites were beamed back to the earth
and the planet's atmospheric composition
and magnetic field were gauged in
addition jupiter was found to emit two
and a half times more thermal energy
than it receives from the sun the data
unique at the time became the basis for
understanding the makeup of gas giants
and their satellites
the trajectory of the second probe
pioneer 11 through space passed jupiter
2 but its main target was the other gas
giant of our system
saturn the probe's scientific
instruments gauged the planet's magnetic
field and the cameras on board took
quite a few snapshots not only of the
gas giant itself and its system of rings
but also two of its satellites titan and
mimas according to the estimates the
current distance between pioneer 11 and
the center of our system is around 106
astronomical units
on completing their main mission both
probes continued on their way moving
further and further away from the sun
unfortunately both of them are out of
range now with the last signal from
pioneer 10 received back in 2003
the last signal from pioneer 11 was
received in 1995
supposedly both of them are now rapidly
moving beyond the boundaries of the
solar system
incidentally having no chance of ever
catching up with either of the two
probes we're going to talk about next
the pioneers were launched at a much
earlier date
spacecraft voyager 1
start of mission
5th of september 1977
distance to earth
154 astronomical units
speed
around 17 kilometers per second or 3.6
astronomical units per year
main goal jupiter and saturn mission
status
successfully completed
condition
not fully operational
the contribution of voyager 1 to the
solar system's exploration can hardly be
overestimated
it is thanks to this probe that several
new jupiter satellites were discovered
alongside its ring system which was big
news
the voyager's cameras captured volcano
eruptions on io and provided hard
evidence that jupiter's great red spot
is an enormous storm
the probe beamed back hundreds of photos
of the largest planet of our solar
system and its satellites
after the spacecraft crossed neptune's
orbit the meters on board sent back a
great amount of valuable data about
interstellar plasma voyager 1 left both
the kuiper belt and the heliopause
behind a long while ago and is now
rapidly crossing the area of the solar
system's scattered disk
making for the inner boundary of the
hypothetical oort cloud it is not only
the remotest man-made object in space
but also the fastest of all the
spacecraft on their way to exit our
system
being the first space probe to have
traveled that far from the center of the
solar system
voyager 1 offered scientists a unique
opportunity to study the heliopause
this is the area around our sun where
solar wind pressure and interstellar gas
pressure balance when the charged
particles emitted by the star collide
with rarefied plasma elaborate
structures form out of elementary
particles and magnetic fields
studying them is crucial for
understanding processes taking place in
the universe
unfortunately by around the year 2025
the power of the radioisotope
thermoelectric generators on board the
probe will have run out completely and
the connection will have been lost in
300 years voyager 1 is estimated to
reach the inner boundary of the
hypothetical oort cloud it will take the
spacecraft approximately 30 000 years to
go clean through
and after that it will fly beyond the
boundaries of the solar system 10 000
years later still the probe will fly by
the star glissa 445 at a distance of 1.6
light years and then it will eventually
get lost in the infinite depths of outer
space
[Music]
speaking about voyager 1 we can't but
mention its twin launched from the earth
on the 20th of august 1977.
voyager 2 had saturn uranus and neptune
for its targets but it also approached
jupiter for a gravity boost it's the
images taken by this probe that allowed
scientists to assume that there are
subsurface oceans on ganymede and europa
on reaching saturn voyager 2 gauged the
gas giant's temperature and magnetic
field and discovered several new
satellites it goes without saying that
lots of snapshots were taken of both
saturn's surface and its rings
next in line on the probe's way were
uranus and neptune
the flyby yielded a great number of
unique snapshots and in total 17 of the
two planet satellites were discovered
also it was found that both uranus and
neptune have ring systems
under neptune's gravitational influence
the spacecraft changed its trajectory
and left the ecliptic plane
this meant that voyager 2 wouldn't be
able to approach the other objects in
the solar system but it still had other
exciting things to look forward to thus
the probe was to collect invaluable data
about interstellar plasma and cosmic
wind as well as to measure distances to
stars and explore the heliosphere
the probe is currently as far as 128
astronomical units away from the center
of our system with a distance growing by
15.37 kilometers every second
it's going to take it around 42 000
years to approach ross 248
a dim red dwarf in the constellation
andromeda
the minimal distance between voyager 2
and the star will be about 1.7 light
years and around 300 000 years since its
launch chances are it will fly by sirius
at a distance of 4.3 light years
unfortunately it is impossible to
distinguish such a tiny object from the
earth that far away
we live at the dawn of space exploration
and interplanetary space probes are just
mankind's first timid steps in exploring
the infinite universe
it is hard to predict their fate
they may be smashed on collision with
the celestial body or they may be
recaptured by our distant descendants
who will have advanced interstellar
travel technologies to the point of
being able to catch up with the probes
for all we know they might recover them
from space and put on display in a
museum
but it is more likely that the fragile
apparatuses are destined to drift on for
years and years through the lifeless
expanses
and millions of years later radioactive
rays and rare particles of cosmic dust
whizzing through the probes time and
time again will eventually wear them
down to threadbare debris to be
scattered across the depths of the
universe without a trace
our journey could certainly have been
much longer as any object in the solar
system is unique and attractive in its
own way we cherish the hope of being
able to update you on each and every one
of them in the future
science is always pushing beyond the
limits and this means that what seemed
just a flight of fancy yesterday may
well become real tomorrow
[Music]
foreign